good morning, i am
particularly pleased, dear federal chancellor,
sebastian, that i can welcome
you to the european
commission this morning in a new and
old capacity, so to speak, i
am very pleased that you are coming to this european commission so early in
your legislative period,
too
of course in our mandate we are
just at the beginning and if i
may allow myself i would like to congratulate you once again
on the formation of a
government but also on the
balanced cabinet with countries and women it is impressive how quickly you managed to do it with consistency
but
also modernity
it's nice when we look at your programme,
which we read with great interest
, that it is a very
ambitious programme, but of
course it has a lot of interfaces with
our european agenda, i
would like to pick out a few points
that we will definitely talk about in our
bilateral g  we will talk about climate protection first and foremost, of
course,
it is impressive to see that
austria has set itself the goal of being
climate-neutral by 2040 and i
see the topic of climate protection,
the fight against climate change, as an
issue for us, too  a new
growth
strategy can be because if we invest very heavily in innovation in clean technologies in the new co2-free process,
then we will be the ones who of course can
also export this knowledge to the rest of the world, but we
can also export these technologies and
products. europe is a
pioneer in this area  but i would
also like to keep this strong position to ourselves
i hope that the
austrian model with these
ambitious goals will set a precedent for
us the second topic that we will definitely
discuss in detail is
migration and it is important to me that
we can join together at around the end of the first
quarter  sustainable concept for you  present e-
migration as a european
commission migration will remain
so we have to get a sustainable and
effective concept on the way
that the whole
chain brings responsibility and everyone has to
participate in the chain of
responsibility, be it with a view to
the countries of origin and their development
be it on the secure protection of
external borders european external borders
must be secure the
fight against inhuman
human smuggling will also be very important
and we will
also need your support there the reform of
dublin or the question of how we
will actually proceed with common asylum
getting things started austria has a high level of credibility with these two issues of
climate protection and migration,
especially with
our eastern member states and
i hope that austria will also be a
blossoming bridge builder to the eastern
member states on these two
issues  we will also talk about the
change if you put it in a
short form almost from the first of february it will be
good old friends but we have to find new
ways together the question of how close
or how far away we will be from each other
especially with a view to the
european single market we will in
it
is clear to us that the closer the
united kingdom is to the rules of the
internal market, the better your access will be, of
course, but
the reverse also applies
, i.e. the united
kingdom must also decide how good its access to the
european internal market is
the western balkans will then also be the largest single market in the world
finally and finally
i know that we both have exactly the
same attitude that is in
our strategic interest to bring the western
balkans as close as possible
to the european union we
both fight very hard for that
especially to north macedonia and
alban  you also have a secure perspective
with accession talks here too you are
playing a
full game and i am counting on you for your
activities there
i would like to end by
congratulating austria because
austria has been a member of the european commission for 25 years since the first of january
so what a
nice double function that we  today
we can also celebrate together a warm welcome to our house,
dear ladies and gentlemen, dear ursula, esteemed commission president,
thank you very much for the invitation,
thank you very much for the opportunity to visit me
here in brussels today,
we have already
worked together in different capacities, but i
I admit it is a
pleasure to meet you here as President of the Commission
and I would also like to thank you from an Austrian
perspective for the way in which
you performed the function,
but also for the priorities
set as the Republic of Austria,
three topics are particularly important to us  first of all,
the competitiveness of
austria and the european union is important,
because that is of course the basis for everything
else, the basis for
people having work, the basis
for tax revenue from which
we can finance welfare state pensions and much
more, and especially in
one  in a changing world in which china
and other parts of this world are
aspiring, i think it is important that we
as the european union
maintain the competitiveness that we
have built up and managed for a long time
secondly, this has already been mentioned
for us the issue of migration is a
central one of the functioning  external
border protection is crucial because we are
convinced that there can only be a
european union without
internal borders if the
external borders are also properly protected
against the traffickers and
people who set off illegally
are turned
back and not to
central europe  come through
and thirdly the fight against
climate change treating
the environment with respect with creation is something
that i think is crucial for the whole world but
especially for the european
union we have now set ourselves the
goal of
becoming climate-neutral by the year
2040  20 30 we rely 100 percent on
renewable energy and
we are of course also pleased that there are
initiatives, for example to
phase out coal, which we in austria have
already decided as the former
federal government, but if this also works
elsewhere in europe then
we think it’s a good thing, especially if  there is no
switch to nuclear power but rather
to renewable forms of energy generation
last but not least we are grateful as a
republic located in the heart of europe to
be firmly anchored in western europe but
traditionally also because of our
history always with good contacts
to eastern europe and we will endeavor to do
our part  to afford
maybe you  e to fill in the gaps that
partially exist within the
european union
and to try to
make a contribution so that the european union is a
strong and united one we are a
small country but of course we want to
actively help shape it i look forward to
working with you and  says
thank you again for the invitation
it was his